cdc recommending booster shots for kids
ages 12 to 15 years old as mary jane
ballessa shows us health experts say it
could help keep kids in the classroom
walgreens is just one of the many
locations where you could get a coven 19
shot as the cdc is recommending that
kids ages 12 through 15 get their
booster shots the cdc says with this
recommendation vaccinated and boosted
individuals don't have to quarantine
after exposure to covin but they should
get tested after five days brian labis
an infection disease epidemiologist at
unlv says the boosters come at a perfect
time as kids are heading back to school
if somebody's been fully vaccinated
within the last six months or they've
received the booster after that time
they don't need to quarantine after an
exposure so it allows us to get kids
back in the classroom after an exposure
without taking them out sonya pedowick a
mom of three teens ages 11 14 and 16
says she's taking her kids to get their
boosters when they're eligible at the
end of the month she says the booster
adds another layer of protection
especially since her youngest child
recently contracted kovid then to be
able to be at school and be protected
and not be the reason why they or
someone else gets sick and labis says
boosting your immune system gives you
the best chance to fight off the virus
regardless of the strain the reason
we're recommending the booster for kids
12 to 15 is the same reason we're
recommending it for everyone over that
over time your immune system wears off a
little bit you don't have the same
strength of protection from that vaccine
as you did when you initially got it and
this gives you a boost mary jane balleza
live local now